look
[Music]
how cristian casares greets you with
his brief information from news now in
spanish if you have recovered from the
coronavirus valley hospitals
hope you can help in the fight
against the pandemic officials from the
local health sector are asking you
survivors to last their
convalescent plasma treatment has
proven to help patients
suffering from the disease and consists
of collecting plasma from a person
who has recovered from the coronavirus
and a transfusion is made to a patient
who is fighting the virus to be able to
donate plasma the public is asked to
call the red cross at 1 800
records to make an appointment at one of
the sites throughout the valley
there is an increase in
coronavirus deaths in the county so
the medical examiner's office is  has been
forced to invest in a new
refrigeration unit so far has not
had to use it but the
coroner is preparing  valley funeral
homes also report being overwhelmed if they
ask the public to take safety precautions
and regulations seriously
and the southern nevada health district
shared new details on
progress
on coronavirus vaccine distribution number
of doses vary  at each site
depending on public demand and
affirms that more appointments will be available very soon
remember not to make an
appointment if you are not within the
approved group to be vaccinated
and the supermarket pharmacy is medium
began to offer the
hobbit vaccine 19 people  seniors
can be vaccinated at any location
by appointment to make an appointment visit the
schmitz website as the
number of doses varies at each site
remember to wait 15 minutes at
the pharmacy after receiving the vaccine
for observation and finally  we passed
with the temperatures for our region
it is anticipated that today will be a sunny day
with the temperatures  Temperatures reaching 60
degrees but apparently today will be the
last pleasant day after a system
that approaches and generates clouds,
winds, rain and even snow for
us, temperatures
will also drop to 40 I am Cristian Cásseres and
this is his own new news bulletin
in spanish
happy thursday
[Music]